nb bâti celle pour qui le casting est
superflu elle les enterre tout voici
chose qui va bien sophie bonsoir est ce
que tu sais que tu es devenu un modèle
pour des millions de jeunes femmes en
france qui veulent comme toi devenir
potiche à la télévision
est-ce que tu conseillerais ce job à
d'autres jeunes filles sophie ouais
ouais
ouais bon
j'aime beaucoup a beaucoup les bijoux
elle n'aime pas tellement ce collier oui
c'était un cadeau peut-être est-ce que
c'est bien payé comme comme travail
ouais
sophie la question qui brûle les lèvres
de tout le monde est ce que tu t'entends
bien avec ton patron on remarquera
qu'elle bouge bien un professeur hervé
halle et excitante
ceci est ce que tu conseillerais à tes
enfants de devenir petit chat leur tour
à la télévision était pas les parents
apprécient tant au ton travail
je te remercie se fit merci beaucoup
applaudi pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de nos latitudes abonnez vous y mettez
un peu de bleu